so it's January 9th which is a very
special day around here it should be a
holiday because it's Gail's 11th
anniversary at CBS News her yellow dress
but she looks beautiful in may look a
little familiar it's the same dress that
she wore on her very first day and she
wears it every year on her anniversary
here to Mark the occasion Gail in
addition to the sweet treats that we put
right here on this table we put together
a little something to celebrate you take
a look okay
once a year on CBS she wears the same
yellow dress as the CBS Morning Post to
the SiriusXM show a Gale King in the
house offers fancy of course we feel
like she's our bestie too okay
[Applause]
I think Serena said not today not today
thousands have gathered they are waiting
for the queen
[Music]
what a week the queen on Monday
house on Wednesday and it's just
Wednesday how hard was it for you to
wear that muscle suit
Michelle Obama
this book the whole time I'm reading it
secretary Clinton I'm going did that
happen to her
tell us about the grilled cheese Shack
it's grilled cheese
great question Gail has it been easy
easy tell us what it took to defend
Johnny Depp why didn't you I don't shot
me I didn't for some reason I was just
trying to protect all of us it was the
most disturbing phone call I'd ever
experienced what was they serving to you
I'm glad that our coverage has called
America decides because this is really
happening America you are deciding when
I first walked in here Otis I got
goosebumps just walking into this room
and all that it represents there you
drive this yeah where are you going in
that okay
here's to another
[Music]
I know here's to you have 35 I have 11.
here's to another 11. I hope there you
go happy anniversary do I hope another
11. yeah yeah you do another 11. I want
to be here but this is the thing guys
when these cupcakes came out I said oh
they're so pretty these came from Whole
Foods I like that the thing Deborah
about the dress when I put it on this
morning James our wardrobe guy said did
you try it on I go no I'm just praying
the sweet black baby Jesus
so so like put on a makeup cake before
you eat that cupcake because that
frosting color will not come out yes yes
yes sir Blakely I thank you there you go
thank you Nate you're welcome thank you
Deborah that'll do it for us we'll see
you tomorrow on CBS Morning